all right this looks good
hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alva tell them your name lady I
was like oh I have a question for you
yes
have you ever seen the channel corridor
crew well they did this wonderful
segment of these VFX artists and they
have these two main second they do a
whole bunch of stuff but there are two
main segments that have really blown up
their channel lately I've been VFX
artist react and stuntmen react
so this VFX artists react is VFX artists
react a bad and great CGI
this is number 17 you don't need to
start from number 1 I mean there might
be like a couple of inside jokes you
won't get that I'm gonna be here going
you've got and you're gonna be like I
don't I don't get it I'm gonna be like
shut up Sally just look pretty ladies
watching Sally on social media because
she needs it
she's an actress yes I'd like to get to
6k please
[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists make
those two great clips for you today and
the jqc gu9 you've ever seen that big
Hollywood actors well you know sometimes
I just feel like nineties movies get a
bad rap The Lawnmower Man I'm a caveman
for not figuring out fire soon enough
[Music]
I've seen these guys I think more people
have seen them and they realize they did
their own ground like anything no it's
like the unsung here is these shots
everything that's not the lion
especially when you realize that
everything is a hundred percent
generated it's not gonna burst open shot
it's of the Sun rising they're clearly
trying to make it look like it's
live-action and Noah is there anything
cartoony about this when you're looking
at a live-action lion you can't have the
emotions that you would get out of the
cartoon characters yes a lot of people
let me see what we're dealing with here
great thing about environments is they
all follow rules
syros units different materials
different rocks being run out by wind
and water and sand and all that kind of
stuff so when the Mahler's are making
this environment they have to follow
those rules for all the things that
subconsciously we can detect very very
quickly like in Avatar they've always
liked floating islands just a lot of
college we're coming from I guess it's
going to clouds so well yeah I wonder
how much yes correct are the more you
can ground it in reality with like using
virtual reality to actually hold the
virtual camera or things like that I
think that how is that what they did all
right let's find a rock or some areas
that I can imagine the scene playing out
on and we photoscan that so keep
throwing out the word photo stands and
what we mean by that is there's a way
you go about modeling really complex
things that exist in your life and the
way it works is basically you take a
bunch of pictures surrounding an object
and then the computer they basically
figures out where these pictures are
overlapping and where they are of the
same detail and from all these
perspectives it can kind of rebuild the
model in 3d
oh wow really good looking environments
in the Sowers battlefront games a lot of
that is just photo scanning and I bet
you really
oh here we go let's see if you look
really good it does look really good
this moment here there's so much of this
movie that is practical whoa I actually
read up this cab 50 feet up into the air
and oh my god out of it but then they
cut to this reversed shot here do you
think this is Wow I think it's actually
a miniature I like a puppet waggling the
truck around is it did actually have a 1
to 6 scale giant Godzilla I respect this
movie now is now the best were they
really computer-generated and I realize
the thing that makes this work most is
they matched the lighting in the black
levels basically the further something
Pakistan more haze that more they wash
out the blacks so you can see in this
shot the to Mozilla are actually at two
different black levels because they
actually have atmospheric perspective in
the shot because he is so big you're
right the left leg which is close to the
camera is not quite as faded it's
actually a little dark very more
contrast it's like just a trick that you
use to separate elements in your shot
easily just like how you would do a non
focus background in a InFocus program
how are Marisa this is really so long oh
my god you haven't seen it no look how
good it looks
I'm honestly kind of impressed by a lot
of the compositing you see in 90s movies
because it's better than a lot of the
stuff you see today using modern
technology yeah
that's why everyone loves that lawnmower
man baby
[Music]
servant tries it out and becomes a
genius by tapping into there's no skin
it's just a year after Terminator 2
obviously it's not nearly as good as
visual effects but we always think of
like the best movies from the 90's as
far as visual effects they're all made
by violin they were neatly and they did
the de-aging now instead of all that
sovereign basically be custom-built so
it wasn't like he just people take that
program there are like dozens of visual
effects they all can kind of do
basically the same level of effects okay
time out time out though if you were
alive and around the time it came out I
thought it was creepy and dumb this is
what a most underrated movies I've seen
it I didn't I didn't mind it I thought
it was gonna be bad but it was you know
we love getting specific shot
recommendations as well
anyways let's check it out there are
over 550
firearms and world that's a green screen
they're feeling in a very dangerous
neighborhood in South Africa right now
like legitimately my productions like we
shouldn't film there in the dirt I want
to Nicolas Cage's like
[Music]
oh now we're looking over there quietly
over the bullet a lot of life lead on
things in the barrel yeah the best movie
openers ever seen it's South America Don
point it kind of ruins the movie really
yep Wow it's one of those like genius
setups where like the way they pre-visit
it and the way they planned it let me go
and execute this on a little budget okay
so I want to talk about some of the
tricks of the day this and the ways they
purchased it the simple techniques to
make it super yeah I want to hear this
bringing all right so this is all shot
in 35 millimeter film so there's no
digital cameras here all the cameras are
huge with actual film reels moving so
when you go into tiny spaces it poses a
problem as a movement of machine here we
move into CG land look through the copy
yeah a pattern a conveyor belt and the
conveyor belt in the bullets are all CG
and this actually is an emotion control
rig it's just the DP of pushing the
camera down to dolly hell yeah so the
fingers grabbing this it's an element
filmed up close like on a green screen
but what they'd often have to do for
that is it actually reprojected onto
geometries make sure to pinch the bullet
correctly and cache shadows and all
stuff they just comp you know the bolsa
program those are probably hand animated
jiggles on the bullets and stuff camera
in a box what leads classic cop shot you
know the boat and stuff in the
background is fake guys on the
green-screen
well the bow is fake it is I know you
don't think about this shot being
actually a really solid the effect shot
all right so this sequence is coming up
here he will have to get the camera to
roll on the ground but as I mentioned
it's a 35-millimeter camera I can't
actually get that low to the ground they
just get the camera as low as it could
they don't roll out they just slide it
so the rolling is done in motion I just
rotated the video clip but they took
that ground plane we protected on just
geometry and then lowered the virtual
camera even lower to the ground to let
them get close to the ground did he pick
up the bullet here posit
so that's the real finger you know post
real but they needed him to load it into
the magazine so they reprojection these
fingers basically onto hotdog shaped
geometry so they could warp the fingers
to make it do the action of pushing the
bullet into the gun honestly a notion
that looks pretty
it does but you definitely see a little
weird warping yeah great way to get
around a little challenging moment just
stitch all these shots together pointer
in the moment these you don't really
notice it this is one of my favorite
sequences what go back to that sequence
mm-hmm we've seen this movie
geez Sally I saw my listen this is all
one shot or it looks like one shot
through them take you're about to get
something very tough them car rig which
is why they're getting these two shots
here this is not green screen they
basically have a camera that's installed
like oh my god so the roof is CG you're
doing a scene we're like the love of
your life is dying popping up turn it
all back on oh my god no idea yeah watch
this movie man normally when you have a
car like this and you have to have a
driver the cars on a trailer of some
sort and someone else is driving the
trailer but we looked through the front
of the car and through the back and
there's no trailer the car has an
extended like seating area basically
right from the front bumper we're guys
just look down the probability of you
hiding cuts is super high I walked
through the scene and there's a light
estimated pinpoints we're 100% there's a
hidden continent wet pants she's shot
this pan there's white I did not see
their head kind of like this Alban dress
they are all now in new costume Anissa
Weier on the single lane Forest Road
right now correct
so like the glass shatter that is a
really awful clear transition point yeah
yeah no character isn't it curious to
see what happens to the road suddenly
now there's markings on the road whoa
the one at the end it's definitely a
hidden camera transition it's not white
going through the window there the
camera goes inside the car I couldn't go
outside masterfully shot tons of hidden
cuts in this that was the hardest thing
for me to track down it's any
information on to life why are these
cuts work so it was really up to us what
hung out will lesson us what's not a
couple years ago yeah apparently he
likes a quarter now a square face is
amazing someone pointed out there
secondly wes is the [ __ ] even in one of
his film the random star filled up there
and now he's like he's a pretty Kevin
Hart to be one of his YouTube shorts
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the original stars oh I can't wait to
check that I want to keep watching more
videos cuz I love seeing how they I
constantly say that I tend to take
things for granted until I watch like
Godzilla 98 is considered absolutely
atrocious though just a terrible film
somehow they made me give a lot to
appreciate them because that whole thing
with like the mechanical Godzilla's the
the fact that they'd built these actual
animatronics and then they have these
like baby Godzilla ever in rubber suits
you got to admire the dedication to
practical that they do for certain
projects where you think they don't need
to do practical but it always helps to
add to this like crazy sense of realism
you know I mean that's about the first
Jurassic Park film is the amount of
practical effects they did and that just
makes it seem waste caring yeah
the shot that they were talking about
with the movie lord of war with the
bullet tracking and ensuring that all
film I can imagine is significantly
or Godzilla mounted shots like that are
always the weirdest ones to me because
it I always ponder like how did they
possibly do that
like what children of men I imagine that
just took an insane level of
choreography as you can see with that
behind the scenes photo with like truly
a more how to pretend she's like
bleeding out and then just lift her
chair up and I didn't realize how much
you'd have to get the actors involved in
really helping out with the shot which I
which I feel like can be really hard as
an actor because you're also having to
be in the emotional moment but then
you're also thinking about the shot and
the Edit at the same time which I feel
like this would be really hard seriously
she likes children a man I don't know
what you're doing your life you call
yourself a aspiring actress aspiring
filmmaker and you haven't seen children
of men
tell you what I'll eventually watch
Shawshank Redemption of Forrest Gump you
watch children haven't seen I know have
you yes
well I'm still a better human okay no
you're right anyway back that Laura horn
mounted shot with the bullet I was
watching this episode of Supernatural
for the first time and just weird shot
it's might be a little disturbing just
to warn you guys this person eats candy
then he discovers that he has like in
the candy is a razor blade in the candy
they have this weird shot where it's
like in his the cameras in his mouth it
was like in the back yeah and I have no
idea how they possibly did that shot I
was assuming there'd be something
sticking out of his mouth to keep it
from falling back and its throat but I
don't even see anything coming back yeah
this looks like a real mouth it looks
like they put a real camera and it has
to be like some fake thing they built or
the dentist camera but yeah because it
looks like a film camera you know that
doesn't look like some like lo-fi camera
that these well I mean he does choke and
he dies spoilers for Supernatural
episode four I mean episode segment he
swallows a few freezer blades it's
supernatural supernatural things happen
in it I'm gonna comment to corridor crew
right now my first comment to them even
though I've commented to them in person
loved the video guys
the there's a shot in Supernatural
Season four Episode seven with razor
blades in a guy's mouth that kind of
reminded me of the shot in lord of war
would love to know what my trying to say
I like how they shot it well they cover
practical and B effects because what
they tend to cover is stuff where the
VFX is used in aid of practical effects
a lot of the time because they call this
VFX artists react to and so every time I
cover one of their videos there's always
someone going exception but it's not
really a react ception because usually
it's like one of the people on the couch
hasn't seen what they're covering are
you going in the middle of my morgue
are you yawning in the middle of me
talking that is rude I'll worry that's a
burp in the middle I actually don't know
what you're talking about okay
you beyond and then burping do you fart
as a rule of three what would you do
afterwards there's a joke there's I'm
gonna transition what they do it's like
they clearly research what they're about
to show us on camera they're doing kind
of a commentary track about it as
opposed to like they're not watching it
all for the first time and then talking
about it you know it's a bit different
than just a full-on reaction but it's a
little reaction to sorts so it's not
exactly react ception well clear that
app does more of an informational video
you get a good film education out of it
which I really appreciate when you could
just watch youtube video honestly
everybody think I think there's no way
you can compose your own film school how
much debt are you
guys go to Sally's patreon page and help
get her out of debt from college because
honestly most times I walk into my
professors or just show YouTube videos
and like I could just people right now
doing the same thing but if you're
planning on going to college or in
college stay in school and keep watching
hoarder crew because you'll learn more
you'll learn more anyway do you like
hoarders video I'm so happy to hear that
Sally your happiness brings me happiness
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects make sure to subscribe to
corridor crew click our notification
bell Sally puts up videos once every six
months
ah no I will keep a lookout go to her
youtube channel follow her on Instagram
always fully clothed don't worry
I make sure she does it that way I'm
like a brother to her yeah so if there's
any bikini photos I go don't be a horse
and also yeah I like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named Josh Josh that's all I got on this
guy so I messaged him two weeks ago when
I get some to give him a personalized
shoutout he messaged me back about a
week late still waiting on another
response found he's from Myrtle Beach
South Carolina it's so hard to get that
his dating profile photo is the same one
on our patreon page I'm gonna show it to
you guys look at that I like to think
that if a woman is going to date a guy
or if you're gay it doesn't matter but
if someone is gonna be sexually
interested in you by looking at your
face it's always better to go below the
eyes thank you you kind of get like a
superhero thing about it it's like
Batman exactly so this is a great photo
tell me you would not date that guy tell
me the opposite no yeah Josh you HOT
[Laughter]
there you go Josh
doubt how complete